economía en france 24 saludo mi
compañera daniela blandón daniela muy
buenas noches comenzamos hablando de la
primera moneda virtual que ha sido
presentada por un banco central de un
país está en el caribe no muy lejos de
acá de cuales santiago muy buenas noches
o sea hay varios países que están
analizando la introducción de divisas
digitales suecia va a empezar un
programa piloto china ya lo está
haciendo y muchos bancos centrales
alrededor del mundo llevan meses
estudiando el tema pero ya es realidad
en cuatro no uno sino cuatro países del
caribe en donde los billetes todavía
tienen impreso el rostro de la reina
isabel segunda porque hacen parte de la
mancomunidad de naciones
estamos hablando santiago de santalucía
granada antigua y barbuda y san
cristóbal y nieves el banco central del
caribe oriental lanzó the catch esta es
una moneda digital basada en block
change que es la misma tecnología
encriptada de las cripto monedas como
bitcoin este sistema que inicia con un
piloto de un año permite que los
usuarios puedan hacer pagos digitales
sin siquiera tener una cuenta bancaria
solo con su teléfono inteligente a
diferencia de las cripto monedas está
así es emitida por una autoridad
monetaria y tiene un valor fijo que
desde un dólar del caribe oriental que
equivale a unos treinta y siete centavos
de dólar estadounidenses uno de los
objetivos es que se reduzca a la mitad
el uso de efectivo para 2025 y que las
transacciones sean mucho más baratas
ahora veremos cómo funciona
daniela a partir de este jueves hay más
exigencia a la hora de elaborar las
etiquetas de los alimentos en méjico en
qué consiste esta normativa si santiago
estas una normatividad que entró en
vigencia en octubre de su primera etapa
para combatir la obesidad en este país
en ese momento se obligaba a que los
alimentos altos en contenidos calóricos
azúcares o grasas entre otros estuvieran
debidamente identificados con letreros
visibles ya pasó la primera etapa ahora
este jueves entra en vigor una segunda
etapa ésta ya se refiere a la
información comercial por ejemplo
santiago un queso que hoy se vende como
tipo mozarella ahora debe decir que es
una imitación y los empaques de
alimentos que no sean saludables no
pueden tener caricatura
y dibujos animados para que no se
fomente su consumo en los niños va a
haber un periodo de transición hasta
mayo para que las empresas se acomoden a
esta nueva norma que ha sido muy
criticada por la industria alimentaria
porque ellos dicen que implican grandes
pérdidas
daniela y nos vamos ahora está bolivia y
ya hay unos resultados preliminares
después de haber impuesto los impuestos
a los super ricos pues este es un
impuesto que ya existe desde hace mucho
tiempo en los países de la región como
colombia y uruguay en argentina
aprobaron uno recientemente también y se
están analizando en otros como chile
méxico y hasta eeuu
bolivia ya lo aplicó desde diciembre y
dijo este jueves que hasta el momento se
han inscrito voluntariamente 182
contribuyentes con un patrimonio mayor a
43 millones de dólares de ello santiago
110 ya ha pagado alrededor de 23
millones de dólares y faltan 72 ya
hablemos ahora del canal de suez todavía
hay barcos en ambos extremos del canal
esperando para poder cruzar esta vía
marítima si señores se cruza el paso que
conecta a europa y asia
fue reabierto hace tres días cuando
pudieron por fin reflotar el
portacontenedores ever given tras
permanecer seis días en callados
inicialmente se había dicho que tomaría
tres días superar el atasco pero serán
más todavía hay casi 200 barcos a la
espera de cruzarlo de un total de más de
400 que quedaron atrapados con miles de
millones de dólares en mercancías ya hay
expertos que incluso han dicho que el
canal de suez debe modernizar su
infraestructura si no quiere que un
incidente como éste se repita y seguimos
viendo las consecuencias económicas
también los indicadores de la jornada de
hoy wall street' inauguró abril con
optimismo santiago el índice standard
and poor's alcanzó un nuevo récord
gracias a las tecnológicas en europa
hubo movimientos leves animados por
datos macroeconómicos pero también por
los anuncios económicos de eeuu y en
américa latina muchas de las bolsas pues
no operaron por ser web esa cifra el día
para el cierre en 2,1 millones de
barriles diarios va a aumentar la oferta
mundial de petróleo la opep más en tres
etapas que inician el primero de mayo
santiago al día se producen en el mundo
100 millones de barriles de petróleo
pero la demanda cayó en casi 10% en la
pandemia así que los países exportadores
a los que se les suma rusia decidieron
cerrar parcialmente los grifos ahora la
demanda está volviendo a repuntar muchas
gracias daniela por este dato gracias a
ustedes por la sintonía es todo por el
momento aquí en france24 siga con
nosotros buenas noches